على الرغم من ان شربت الزبيب يصنع في اغلب
المحافظات العراقيه الا انه يتميز في
صناعته بمدينه الموصل بطعم مختلف عن
المناطق الاخرى فطريقته تحضيره تمر بمرحله
الحج وهي فصل الحبوب او البزور على العنب
الاسود المجفف هذا فضلا عن اضافته عشبه
النعناع الى الخلطه وذلك بعد غسله ونقعه
لاربعه وعشرين ساعه
طريقه الزبيب عندنا الزبيب او بالبدايه
نغسلهم الشوايب نرجع نحلجه بالماكينه مال
الحليج ونرجع نخليه الاكياس اكياس
وترجعوا اسبابه وانتشار عصير الزبيب في
المائده الرمضانيه الموصليه وكذلك سكان
المحافظات الاخرى في اقليم كردستان العراق
الى تراجع زراعه النخيل على مر العصور في
هذه المناطق بسبب الطقس البارد تستبدلوا
التمور بعصير الزبيب المجفف الذي ذاع صيته
وبات جزءا اساسيا للمائده العراقيه
لاعتقاد الصائمين انه يعوض السكريات التي
يفقدها جسم صائم شربه اهميه بالعد
الصائمين بالموصل لان يحتوي على فوائد
كثيره يعني نحن كسائمين نشربه
الطاقه خلينا نقاوم فتره الصيام الطويله
اللي
عشناها
يعني يحتوي على السكريات
الطاقه لهذا نعتبرك شربه مفضل عندنا نحن
كسائمين بالموصل وتحصلوا العائلات والمحل
التجاريه المختصه بصناعه عصير الزبيب على
امدادات الزبيب محليا حيث تاتي كميات
كبيره منه من جبال كردستان العراق القريبه
من الموصل بالاضافه الى بساتين العنب
المنتشره في بعض المحافظات العراقيه
الاخرى احمد الحمداني العربيه اربيل